alice
is with us in houston texas hi alice how
are you
all right how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i work and
i drive uh for rideshare
and right now i'm renting a vehicle
uh to do it um
i was people telling me i need to buy my
own ride
um but so i did baby step one
i haven't did baby step two um
so do you think i should buy a ride or
should i keep bringing a rat
well here's the thing alice with the
rideshare programs i do know for an
example
uh for i'm not saying name the companies
but you got to have at least
a car 10 year old no more than 10 years
old
so it sounds like you're not in a
position to do that financially right
now
okay now is this ride sharing program is
this the only
source of income you have right now
coming in or is this a side gig and you
have another full-time job
no i do this full time
yeah so what are you making
anywhere from age on up a week
800 a week oh yeah okay 800
well 800 plus yeah yeah and what's so
what's the rental costing you
i think like maybe
seven a month so you're working for free
no so 700 a month 700 a month yeah not a
week
oh okay i'm sorry yeah
yeah 700 a month and so you're like
renting from a rent-a-car company
yes yeah interesting well here's the
thing
alice you can honestly um and grab me
from your own dave on this one
because i i'ma say i don't have a
problem with you renting
if you're stacking up money to go buy
cash so for an example we're in 2020
going to
2021 that means you can get a 2011
car okay long just 2011 or or newer
you can buy something no it has to be a
2015
sorry yeah 2015 2015 or higher so yeah
so that's gonna run you about in
in between seven and ten thousand
dollars how old are you
50. what was your last job
um my last job was
uh auction
was what working for auction
auction okay what were you making there
that was just very that was just like a
little
part-time alright like
okay what you're describing uh scares me
because i'm afraid there's some costs
involved here
or some lack of insurance that's
involved here that might be
setting you up for all kinds of problems
i certainly wouldn't sign you up for a
700 car payment or a car payment at all
in order to do ride share but if we're
gonna move to
move away from this whole thing then we
have to have a replacement for it you
got to eat
yes and you've been using this to eat i
get that uh i like your ingenuity you
came up with some cool ideas and some
you you scratched around figured out a
way to make a dead gum living good for
you
uh i'm a little bit afraid whoever
you're running the car from might
not uh be okay under the contract you've
signed with you using it for ride
sharing
and i'm a little bit afraid that the
ride sharing people might not be okay
with the with the type of insurance and
the fact that you're driving a rental
car to do
i don't know there's just there's a lot
of stuff in here that's
that's bothering me 700 a month
bothering me a lot too it's obviously
bothering you
um she has to get a car day yeah but i
215
a 2015 to drive for that company maybe
you drive for a different one
yeah uh but uh i mean i don't know what
the guidelines are with the different
cars
i know one of them it has to be ten
years or newer
okay like uber yes i don't know i don't
want to say it
say whatever i don't care yeah uber will
allow you to do that i don't know what
lift
if lyft has a lesser or whatever but uh
so
a lot of drivers that i know drive for
both uh and it's usually a side gig
too yeah so i i would start saving
aggressively
and buy a car very very quickly yeah
like
and i'd be working like 24 7.
i'd be working all the time to get out
of this because i'm afraid
you're in a trap but would i go buy a
car on payments i've never told one in
30 years of doing
told anyone in 30 years of doing this
show to go borrow money and i'm not
going to start today
so i wouldn't but if i woke up in your
shoes i would
work like a maniac and pile up enough
cash in about a month to go do this
um and you know you're coming into the
holidays you probably can get
really busy yeah uh in houston texas
because yeah that that's what i'm gonna
do yeah
yeah let's solve this in 30 days yeah or
45 days
and go buy a car and even if you bought
a lesser car and you couldn't drive for
that same company for a period of time
then you move do the same thing again
then move up in car
later yeah but do it with cash and stay
out of the payment business
i would not do what you're doing uh for
a for a long term plan because i think
there's holes in it
and i'm afraid you're gonna get uh get
caught in a mess
uh i'm making this up i'm not sure it
just
make it just feels wrong the possibility
of the mess is dave because i tried uber
you know just to test it out for myself
you have to provide
a registration and proof of insurance so
i don't know how she's doing that
because she doesn't have proof of
insurance she well
you can get insurance through the rental
car company yeah she doesn't have
registration
exactly she doesn't own the car and the
insurance is not her insurance it's the
rent-a-cars and experience company
i know so i don't i don't you got me
yeah it just it sounds like somebody
yeah it's tricky that's true so all
righty all right that's
what we're gonna do the the second idea
other than just pile up some cash really
quick and then keep doing this
is ask yourself okay i'm 50 years old
what i want to be doing when i'm 65
probably not uber no
probably want a career field you
probably want to start setting some
longer goals and saying
okay what have i got to do to get out of
this car what have i got to do to move
into something else that's why i was
asking about your previous career
what are you trained in what can you do
and so okay
i'm going to start taking some once we
get this solved let's start taking some
classes
let's do whatever we've got to do to
move into the career field that you
really want to do
and hang on i'll give you a copy of ken
coleman's book and help you move that
direction it's called the proximity
principle
and um yeah i i think that's going to be
your longer term better answer
yeah that's the is the way this feels to
me so
uh i know what you're doing is not going
to be sustainable
uh and i know even if you get into your
own car
that you can use and you can make the
same kind of money or more money and you
won't have a 700
payment you'll be making pretty decent
money at that point but you're working
your butt off yeah and what is the
long-term aspects of that
probably not your plan so we need a
long-term plan and a short-term plan
and you're really really hard-working
lady
really smart you're coming up with ideas
you're scrappy to get out there and
scratch around find some money i'm proud
of you
do that but let's get this situation
fixed and it's not a car payment to fix
it
this is the dave ramsey show